hey guys and welcome back to roller
coaster in three today I want to lay the
groundwork for the German area and one
more too much is happening in this
episode I actually think quite a lot
happened for the time span in which it
was recorded which is about three hours
but all I'll actually work on is the
first German facade over here just so
just so you can kind of get a style of
what this entire area is going to look
like because there was there is
definitely a lot of planning behind this
area and I to be quite frank I planned
it out a lot more than all the other
areas so you should hopefully see that
develop over time but I really wanted to
get this episode out there just to get a
sense of the general style of building
and something that I want to keep of
course throughout the rest of this area
of the park and just kind of see how it
develops and actually really like it in
hindsight and hopefully it's something
which people are into two and i haven't
actually received much feedback from
actual german people too so i might get
roasted on this I should probably
actually explain a bit more about the
choices that I've made why I've made
them like that basically I want to make
a bavarian type village over here or at
least before Ian styled facades and the
reason why I want to do this and I think
of us I wrote I've already talked about
this in the last episode but they still
keep that sort of stucco elements that
you would see in the English areas i
think it transitions really well from
that area but you also see the stock
elements in the austrian areas that's
really good as well and they have the
same general sort of building shapes
with just the normal forage roofs and
sticking that right to the front where
you sort of have that facade and what i
actually also like about it is the fact
that before Ian the Bavaria is the
southern parts of Germany or at least
one of the southern Boone is Lana of
Germany I know I shouldn't go into that
too much I'm also sorry about butchering
any German names by the way but that's
why I think it's also the best choice
since I want to have a mountain as a
sort of centerpiece of the Alpine area
but this will combine both the
Austrian and the German area and what I
might possibly still get in the future
so I wanted to make sure that I wouldn't
get like some sort of northern German
style which wouldn't fit with a mountain
in front of this area so hopefully the
looks of the buildings eventually are
gonna work very nicely with the enormous
well sort of large mountain that I want
to have in the middle of this area where
I probably want to have a my train in
the future that's a bit about that
anyway the basic sort of way that I'm
gonna make these buildings and where I
actually took a lot of inspiration from
is a couple of very specific towns in
Bavaria but one in particular where you
might really say that it's more than
inspiration and sometimes just a blatant
ripoff from a town called Rosenberg
again sorry if I butcher any of the
names but it's really a town where
because you know I was looking for
different Germantown's to decide on what
type of style I want to go for and
really just found that Rosenberg is the
one that I like most and also feel like
is very a sort of general atmosphere
which you can easily make and roller
coaster get three with the existing sets
out there and the general idea of this
area based on that town is that all the
buildings have this sort of 4h roof
shape pointing toward the front wherever
the street or large plaza is and
buildings are quite colorful and which
is a lot of fun to work with actually so
there'll be many brown but also white
green and blue buildings and not all of
the buildings but many of the buildings
also have some stucco elements to them
which is really cool as well and of
course there are many medieval sort of
leftovers influences in there as well so
a lot of fun of being able to mess with
medieval towers and stuff like that it's
also something that I want to do in this
area but yeah you can basically see the
overall just of what i want to do over
here in this building that you can see
here which is one of the buildings where
i didn't want to have some stucco
elements but again you see those very
colorful walls pretty standard Alpine
for the rest I have to say because
there's one of the things that I would
also probably like to talk about when it
comes to
this area this is very much within my
comfort zone if there's anything out
there having roller coaster go through
that fits right into my computer and
it's any type of Alpine theme which is
on one hand really good because it means
that it's really hard to actually mess
up on this since I can always sort of
fall back into that experience but I
also feel like it's a major pitfall
since if you start talking about falling
back into experiences just to save
yourself from any type of disaster and
just play it safe with what you're used
to don't really get as creative and
start doing many new things which is
what I did want to do over here so
there's some new things that I've never
actually tried and one of them is really
how colorful these buildings is isn't
something that I've done often in Alpine
themes the colors of the word as much as
a minor point as it may seem is that I
very usually especially with Australian
theme I go for these more greyish darker
shades of brown but in this case decided
to actually go with a very red ish shade
of brown which is actually done very
peachy color if you look at the color
table which is something that I've
barely used with wood before only in
real tropical cases really like that so
far too and of course you just wanted to
mess with some different sets and pieces
that I haven't actually tried with this
theme before like random Disneyland sets
and stuff like that so it should
hopefully still be okay but yeah
definitely i'm really happy about how
this area came out but then again it's
if I failed on this area I would be
pretty mad at myself since it's just
something that I've done or at least
I've done similar type of themes many
times before anyway over here I just
wanted to have a small Tower which is
sort of goes back to the towers that you
would see in wattenberg where these city
walls have towers at its entrances it
also actually has times the middle of
the town and this is the sort of design
that also wanted to use over here but
it's also sort of the idea that you see
in Linda which has a tower in its harbor
and I figured sort of sneaking that idea
of a random tower to spice up a Plaza I
would place a towel
inside the river over here and just
decorate that I'm s a bit with that
which was also quite a lot of fun to do
it's quite interesting actually is that
this tower is well something that fits
right up in my comfort zone in some ways
definitely used all those sets which are
used in here quite a lot of times
including Ralphie's medieval and
Ralphie's Newcastle sent and also
station James castle things too but in a
different way than i would have usually
used them especially the use of actually
the darker red edge bricks over here and
the different combinations of sense
actually turn out pretty good i think in
the end but i do have to be quite blunt
I have no exact idea what the real
function of this tower in a city
environment would realistically be but
the little greyish cobblestone next to
the tower is where I want to have a flat
ride in the future so for the park
purposes this is sort of a very neatly
disguised control room for a flat ride
that's going to be next to it which is
overly neat of course but it's a
weighted least make use of this building
which I wanted to do and I didn't want
to actually have to mess with some sort
of control room that usually really
sticks out like a sore thumb if you have
a very heavily themed area but yeah
quite happy about how this tower turn
out even if this is one of the things
where I really feel like it's less of
just an ode to the Rosenberg but more of
an extremely heavy inspiration or anyway
just completely ripping off from it
because it's very very similar to many
of the towers that you'd find not just
in rosenberg but just about everywhere
it's a theme which I really find doesn't
really allow you to be too creative so
I'd rather just mess with different sets
and types of windows and things like
that which I haven't really tried before
but aside from that it's a pretty
standard thing which have done many many
many times again before I mean but yeah
this is this little thing the flat right
and that's gonna be in front of this
building by the way will not even be
built yet just really felt like
placing this thing here and quite
honestly these barrels over here are
more of a placeholder at the moments
they actually weren't supposed to be
actually placed them there thinking that
the barrel ride would fit Germany okay
not entirely great but there's quite a
lack of custom flat rides out there that
are really suitable for certain themes
and I figured you know this is Germany
we can have barrels in some way but
somebody actually pointed towards the
fact that right at the other side of the
gates to England there's already a
different teacups ride and this barrels
ride is ready just the teacups in
disguise so I'll change that in the
future that's nothing to worry about
just keep in mind that this is sort of a
placeholder at the moment and I'll
definitely do something else with it in
the future I was something I wanted to
try in this area as well is to get much
more dynamic parts because that's
something which especially the English
area I feel really missed out on and
this is something which I like like to
do but I feel like I forgot at some
point early in the park to actually have
not just curvy paths but also make sure
that they interact and aren't just go
straight everywhere so I really wanted
to do as much as I could do over here to
make the paths more interesting which
means that I wanted to have that little
bit of terraforming over there to make
sure that you know not just the mountain
on the other side of the river room
would be terraforming but the the little
town over here at least thats some
differences in height as well really
helps with the facade too by the way to
have some slight differences in height
and also have some building stick out
more than other buildings but yeah I
also wanted to get that just to make me
part a little bit more dynamic and of
course those planters adds extra curves
because the more curves you have
generally on the path the better it is
usually and of course some direction
alongside the water in the future as
well and really happy about how that
turned out in the end but that's
something you'll probably have to see it
later stages to something that I do want
to mention especially as we as i get so
many roofs done in this episode at this
point in time is that i think the
biggest issue at the moment that makes
this look unrealistic or at least the
just a problem that I potentially see in
this area is the fact that i use tile
roofs if i actually wanted to make this
realistic i would have to use what are
they called again [ __ ] i forgot right i
had to use slated roofs and also they
should have a little bit of a darker
texture than the roofs that i have at
the moment and it actually really just
comes down to the fact that there aren't
any slated roofs that have the exact
color and pieces that I'm looking for
and this tile roof set sort of looks
like the same colon texture it just
isn't entirely what I'm looking for but
yeah if I didn't go for this and go went
for a available slated roof sense which
with which does have the right colors I
would end up with Ralphie's medieval
where the roofs actually come with walls
as well which is really annoying you can
see the Ralphie's medieval texture on
this very narrow one tile building in
between here which is sort of used as a
filler where I was able to use that war
because it is just a one edge where I
was able to use that roof since it was
just a 1-h roof which doesn't really do
much else but I really needed the
flexibility of the tile roof sets so
that's in the end why I did go with the
tile roofs that I might go back and
actually make some slated roofs if I
ever don't feel like it lazy fellows but
so far I'm not really looking forward to
that so really just keeping the tile
roofs for now I don't think they're too
big of an issue but it's for me at least
the biggest potential issue in what
could make this area not look that
realistic but overall I'm quite happy
about it of course you can always give
me some feedback on how I could
potentially make it more German or
what's wrong with it but so far I'm
really quite happy with it one thing
that I might say is that there's
actually a lot of stucco and that there
are more details then are realistic for
this type of theme and this type of town
but then again that's also bear freedom
i want to take in the name of theme park
design and just make these houses look a
little bit more interesting and not just
leave empty houses without any stucco
details or such Oh
really detailed pillars and arches
because quite honestly I just have a lot
of fun adding these little arches nooks
and crannies and stuff like that it
actually is a lot of fun but yeah the
buildings are all quite similar but I
wanted to make sure that every building
would have their own little style of
either having stucco or not having
stucco and having her own little style
of what types of color it uses or what
type of cornerstones it uses and
different windows for different
buildings as well just to make sure
there's some subtle differences there's
actually a very interesting video on
this sort of city design which what's
the very long time ago which is
something that really reverberates that
sentiment that you want to have
buildings that sort of look the same and
fit together and this is especially
rural in many of these old medieval town
towns i mean the the one I have
buildings that sort of fit together and
each of them has their own creativity
and their own style in a way but they
should all also fits together neatly and
really look like one harmonic sort of
town scene in a way so that's why I
really wanted to make sure that the
details and every building looks the
same over here but the buildings are
only at max 4 h difference in height so
they all have the same heights they all
have a very similar shape and structure
and none of them really deviate too much
from the other buildings this is
something that I really wanted to get in
here to really get that idea of you know
a variety of building and a bit of chaos
in there but still make it or organized
and not look too sloppy and random but
make sure that it's all within the same
theme and that's the general idea so
really that's also the way that I
technically went about this just sending
the rules of different walls and
different ways of going about doing the
stucco and anning windows and doors and
cornerstones and things like that and as
soon as you have that down as long as
well as the shape of the houses you can
just sort of start building and follow
the rules for each building but change
them a little bit and add some unique
elements and that
general I find it's a lot of fun but
also quite good about guideline to get
your towns and your facades ready so
that's why I really went with for this
town and this is how it turned out I
suppose I really had to add these couple
of buildings over here at the end with a
little less stoker because it was quite
a lot of stucco especially on those
buildings with the pillars underneath it
but really overall quite happy one of
the things which I didn't quite finish
in this episode though so even though it
might seem like this facade is finished
is to make it actually seemed alive and
this is this is almost half of the work
it's really important I think to make
things look alive but ending small signs
and some small tables and chairs outside
of them and things like that i knows
perhaps some small flowers and some
baskets with flowers and flower boxes
flowers just in general make things look
really live and some very subtle foliage
here and there as well so those are the
things that i want to get to in a future
but yeah this is the facade thanks for
watching and see you guys next time